[Music]
Belgium ridiculed by some for being
boring
has now become Europe's cocaine
trafficking capital
criminal groups from the Western Balkans
have proved to be very entrepreneurial
in 2020 the port of Antwerp accounted
for 40 of all cocaine seizures in the EU
cocaine is perhaps the ultimate criminal
steroid it's brought Corruption of the
local authorities and violence to the
streets
within 10 years we will end up having
Narco state
so how did this happen
happy thing can be can be curb the
wealth and power of the traffickers
[Music]
June 2020 just outside the Belgian Port
of Antwerp armed police are about to
swoop on a warehouse
inside they find shipping containers
full of tools used by a sophisticated
cocaine trafficking cartel
a torture cell complete with dentist
chair and sound insulation and a stash
of fake police uniforms
[Music]
if you see that the criminal
organizations are putting in place
containers with torturing if you see
that they are using uniforms in order to
do their stuff this is of course
frightening
Antwerp has become a key hub for
importing cocaine from South America
into Europe
in recent years there have been record
and increasing seizures of cocaine at
the port
this one was a container with a bananas
coming from Colombia you can see here a
darker Moss where we checked that out
two tons of cocaine
shipping containers are the arteries of
most International Trade legal and
illegal
the low-cost high volume advantages they
give legitimate industry are equally
valued by the most lucrative form of
global criminal business drug
trafficking
here we have a little container that was
found inside of a big container it
appeared to be full of drugs so not even
hidden between other Goods just a whole
small container filled with 11 tons of
cocaine
in 2021 over 100 tons of cocaine were
seized in Belgium that's over one-fifth
more than the Netherlands which seized
the second highest amount in the
European Union
law enforcement agencies estimate they
only catch around 10 percent of the
total cocaine smuggled through Antwerp
their business model is to ship
massively in as many containers as
possible and then they know okay we're
going to lose the 10 or 20 percent
few Industries could survive such a loss
of product
so why do cocaine traffickers risk using
Antwerp for repeat business
because they like legitimate companies
can rely on the infrastructure and
Logistics that Europe's second biggest
and furthest Inland Seaport offers
a huge variety of global Goods pass
quickly through Antwerp and are
distributed across the continent fast
whether that product is coffee
counterfeit or cocaine
illicit markets operate in many of the
same ways as illicit markets so the same
ports that are being used to smuggle
drugs are also the ones that were moving
everything else in
on average 12 million containers move in
and out of Antwerp each year and only
around two percent of containers are
physically checked by the authorities if
you are a trafficker the opportunities
for hiding drugs within this sheer
volume of trade are ample and fruitful
bananas are a very popular way to
smuggle cocaine from Latin America to
Europe because they are one of the main
products that Latin America countries
export to Europe and because bananas are
perishable Goods so the pressure is on
to rush them through customs
the traffickers decide to piggyback off
this efficiency and to play the numbers
game the port of Antwerp makes its money
because it can get a container off the
ship and onto transport to its next
destination in an extremely short time
it's simply not possible for them to
search millions of containers and this
is what the traffickers are depending on
and have traditionally independent
[Music]
so whether you're importing cocaine
methamphetamines or counterfeit medicine
the port of Antwerp is an excellent hub
for Distributing across Europe
this makes it especially attractive for
cocaine traffickers because consumption
has increased in Europe over the last
decade
crucially it's now a more lucrative
Market than North America
Europe became a business no-brainer for
cocaine traffickers because one the
price is higher of a kilo of cocaine in
Europe than in the United States to much
less risk of interdiction and three much
less risk of extradition so more Awards
less risk
many European mafias sought to exploit
this profitable opportunity further by
controlling more of the supply chain
some carved out a reputation for both
reliability and extreme violence
those from the Balkan countries such as
Albania Croatia and Bosnia
in the 1990s and 2000s the Balkans
endured years of war and conflict the
destruction of economies pushed some
towards crime the Balkan mafias have
taken the knowledge of violence and
Toleration for violence from the Balkan
War
they had access to weapons they had
language skills
criminal groups from the Western Balkans
have proved to be very entrepreneurial
from heroin
cannabis cultivation and the human
smuggling and tobacco smuggling to a
more lucrative business that is cocaine
trafficking
Vulcan traffickers together with other
European mafias have proved resourceful
importers expanding shipment routes
between South America and Europe
previously cocaine would mainly travel
from Colombia and enter Europe through
its Southern ports
Balkan Mafia groups traveled upstream
and like a multinational with its
subsidiaries have built connections all
over Latin America including in new
export countries such as Ecuador and
also smuggled product using new routes
through northern European ports
these sophisticated transnational crime
federations have boosted their profit by
taking control of the shipping from
Latin America to Europe
in other words they now control the
whole supply chain the main profit
margin in the cocaine industry is not in
the retail sale it's not in the
production it is in the transport the
markups for production the profits are
about 150 percent
the retail markup is about 300 percent
the transport marker depending on where
you go to Europe it is 1500
unlike normal businesses cocaine
traffickers can deploy extreme violence
to ensure product delivery and they can
also employ corruption as shown by the
Albanian Kingpin driten rajepi is
without any doubt the successful model
of the Balkan criminals cocaine
emissaris in Latin America It is
believed that there are JP arrived in
Ecuador in 2011 after he escaped a
prison in Belgium
driten rajepi was imprisoned in Ecuador
in 2014 but that didn't stop him running
a highly profitable cocaine Empire
his enormous profit meant he could
afford to buy off officials not only in
Latin America but also in wealthy
European countries
journalist artan hoja has interviewed
rajepi
[Music]
Landings in Antwerp cost the
organization 20 to 24 of their cargo so
if they shipped 100 kilograms from
Ecuador they would pay bribes 20 to 24
kilograms of product or the equivalent
in cash
foreign
vast profits have allowed traffickers to
increase the budgets they have for
bribery the kind of Corruption of
officials traditionally associated with
poorer countries is becoming
increasingly common in Europe
if you're trafficking cocaine and you're
making these quite remarkable
levels of profit then that just becomes
a cost of sales
there was a hope that with the
possibility of countries from the
Western Balkans joining the European
Union the Western Balkans would come to
look more like the EU what we see is
that in some countries of the EU they're
starting to look more like the Western
Balkans
[Music]
back in Belgium this is a problem the
head of Customs freely admits to
traffickers have bribed Port officials
to turn a blind eye to Containers full
of cocaine arriving at Antwerp
today I have two people who are in jail
because they supported the criminal
organizations you help them say this
container you don't put it on this part
of the terminal you put it on another
place you can earn 50 000 Euros it's
easy money
and there are worrying signs in this
corner of Europe that corruption extends
Beyond Port workers right up to the top
remember this container full of 11 tons
of cocaine with a street value of up to
three quarters of a billion euros
the seizure led to the arrest of the
former head of antwerp's anti-narcotics
section three police officers and a
lawyer
big corporations often Lobby politicians
traffickers deploy a different kind of
pressure group because if a bribe isn't
an option the bullet is
the mayor of Antwerp needed 24 7 police
protection after speaking out against
drug mafias
they have the money to influence
politics and so on so the what is the
worrying part for me in this War on
Drugs is what the cocaine has done in
South America one should not be naive
what is possible in South America is
also possible in Europe
despite Belgian police launching their
largest ever operation against organized
crime in 2021 the head of Customs has
little faith the traffickers can be
stopped at present the effect on the
criminal organization remains minor we
seize a lot with the prices on the
market plane they remain the same
so what can be done to Halt this vast
illegal trade coming through Belgium
those working in enforcement argue more
and better resources are essential for
taking on the traffickers
Belgian Customs officers want the
ability to scan 100 of containers coming
into the country
if not enough means are put available to
the law enforcement agencies here then
within 10 years we will end up having
Narco state in Antwerp
others argue a more coordinated
International response is needed to the
global phenomenon of illicit trafficking
this requires good transnational
cooperation at the moment the criminals
cooperate much more effectively than the
police
but curbing
because will take more than improved
enforcement
globalization has led to a quadrupling
of the number of containers over the
last 20 years across the world
opportunities for hiding and trading
criminal cargos are endless
if we weren't one thing about the
so-called War on Drugs it is that
International criminals have an
unlimited capacity for adaptation
to tackle drug trafficking a rethink is
needed about what should be considered
criminal that will require a radical
change of strategy by government towards
focusing on Medical Solutions to drug
use and legalizing production and
distribution in order to break the
gangster's grip over the drug business
the great hope is that you take away
fast financial resources from some of
the worst people on earth
the War on Drugs cannot be won as a war
foreign
[Music]
Deputy editor at The Economist if you'd
like to learn more about this topic
click on the link opposite thanks for
watching and don't forget to subscribe